we have a function right over here
defined as an infinite series and what i
want to attempt to do in this video is
to see if we can express it in a more
traditional form
and so the thing that might jump out at
you is well look if this is a geometric
series we know how to take the sum of an
infinite geometric series at least over
the x values where the thing will
actually converge and so let's first see
if this is a geometric series
well the the telltale pattern of a
geometric series is when you go from one
term to the next you're multiplying by a
common ratio so let's see to go from two
to negative eight x squared what do you
have to multiply by we have to multiply
by negative four
negative four x squared so we multiplied
by negative 4x squared now do we
multiply by that same amount to get to
32x to the fourth well sure negative 4x
squared times negative 8x squared is
going to be positive 32x to the fourth
multiply by negative 4x squared again
you're going to get to negative 128x to
the sixth so the common ratio is
negative 4x squared our first term is 2.
so we can rewrite this we can rewrite f
of x
as being equal to the sum
from n equals 0 to infinity
of you see let's see our first term here
is 2
2 times
negative 4
x squared to the
to the
nth power this is a geometric series
where our common ratio is negative 4x
squared to the nth power now when
when will this thing right over here
converge well we know that a geometric
series will converge if it's common
ratio if the absolute value of its
common ratio is less than one
so let me write this down so converge
converge if
the absolute value of the common ratio
negative 4x squared is less than 1.
well this the way it's written right now
is going to be a negative value so the
absolute value the absolute value of
this is just going to be
x squared right x squared is going to be
or i should say this is going this is
going the way
x squared is going to be non-negative
so 4x squared is going to be
non-negative negative 4x squared is
going to be non-positive
so if you're taking the absolute value
of a non-positive thing that's going to
be the same thing as the absolute value
of the negative of it
so this just has to be
less than one and the absolute value of
something that is strictly non-negative
like this well that's just going to be
four x squared these two statements are
equivalent and that has to be
less than one can divide both sides by 4
you get x squared is less than 1 4 and
so we can say that the absolute value of
x
the absolute
value of x has to be less than 1 4 or we
could say that
negative 1 4 has to be less than x which
has to be less than positive 1 4. so
expressed this way we're giving the
interval of convergence
this thing will converge as long as x is
in this interval expressed this way
we're really saying the radius of
convergence this will converge as long
as x is less than our radius of
convergence as long as x or as long as
the absolute value of x is less than our
radius of conversion as long as x does
not go
as long as x stays less than 1 4 away
from zero to make it a little bit
clearer you could rewrite this as the
distance between x and zero as long as
this this you could use as the distance
between x and zero as long as this stays
less than one-fourth this thing is going
to converge so this is the interval of
convergence this you could view
one-fourth you could view as the radius
of convergence now with that out of the
way we've thought about where this thing
converges let's think about what it
converges to
well we've done this multiple times this
is going to be equal to
our first term 2
over
1 minus our common ratio
minus our common ratio our common ratio
is negative 4x squared
4x squared so this is going to give us
and we deserve a drum roll
over 1 plus 4
x squared so this expression
is going to be equal to this as long as
x is within our interval of convergence